sam hinches is going to get the start
today for cleveland and who knows how
deep he'll be able to get into the ball
game you know as an opener he hasn't
pitched a lot you're figuring maybe one
time through the order maybe two innings
reds have a man 90 feet away two ounce
and now the man who serves as the reds
d.h tonight joey votto
vato rips into that hanger
lash to right
india scores
motto stays hot and the reds lead one to
nothing wherevato's swing right now is
just so tight this is a hanging breaking
ball yes but i mean he stays right on it
his head stays perfectly still nice
short compact stroke reds are 39 and 13
when scoring first that win percentage
of 750 tied for third best in baseball
and it is nino day luis castillo gets
the start
and that is a fair ball over the bag and
down the line it goes
mile straw into second base with a lead
off double so the indians have the tying
run and scoring position with nobody out
here in ending number one ahmed rosario
to the plate
slow chopper to third work suarez with a
glove and a throat it's not in time
that's right an infield single for
rosario and miles straw able to move to
third
and they've got him at the corners with
nobody out here
to start the game
high fly ball center field i don't know
if this is defunct but not aquino
settles up
with strong straw is not going to test
the arm that's a good one
okay indians at the corners one down
and the dh is fran mill reyes
and a slow chopper to third they get the
force there and india
is
a little slow to get up i don't know if
he got spiked rosario with a hard slide
into second
to make sure there would be no double
play the indians tied the game at one on
the fran mill reyes fielder's choice rbi
and now there are two men out for harold
ramirez swinging in a miss he struck him
out with a high fastball up and out of
the zone down on strikes harold ramirez
and the inning is over hey eugenio
suarez leading out for cincinnati
he's down on strikes to start inning
number two first strikeout for sam
henches one away that brings rstd's
aquino to the plate
smashes that one over short hard single
to left a one-out runner and so the reds
with back-to-back singles here in the
second inning here's jonathan indian and
it's swung on bounce to third ramirez to
second there's one relay to first by
ximena's double play
well sam henches
if he were a cat he's down to seven
lives but he's still pouncing and needs
to get the lead off man aboard here's
catcher wilson ramos swung on hit pretty
well to right castianos is back it's
over his head gone
wilson ramos
with an opposite field two-run home run
to right
he's played in a couple of games with
the indians and he's hit home runs in
each of them and the indians have a
three to one lead here in the second
inning there's justin garza takes over
here in the third now nick castellanos
winker aboard nobody out
nice
nice sequence there really is coming
back after the leadoff walk that's huge
to get the dangerous castillanos that'll
bring up joey bottom swing and a miss
down goes vano back-to-back case for
justin garza and there are two down here
in the third and you see bottle couldn't
get it straight down so you see him
made two really good pitches to two
really good hitters
oh a late call rings him up
third strikeout for garzer all in a row
after the leadoff walk to winker well on
to first is rosario and here's ramirez
and there's a high drive deep center
field beck is aquino he's out of room
it's off the wall
i'll bet rosario kicking it into gear
he's gonna be waving around third
the throw will not be made
it's an rbi triple for jose ramirez and
a 4-1
indians lead
oh jose ramirez by inches missing a
two-run home run to right-center he's
still looking out there going what do
you mean that ball didn't get out of
here the last time he gave up four runs
in a game was may 29th and now the
indians have two on with one out of
bradley zimmer coming up a swing and a
grounder to first bobbled recovered
stevenson steps on the bag throws wide
to second and then going back to first
safely as ramirez and to score is jose
ramirez so heads up base running by
harold ramirez he stepped on the bag at
first he threw wide to second
diving catch by farmer but harold
ramirez saw the die
and then he stopped running to second
and scampered back to first and now two
on two out for owen miller
tapper back to the mound castillo
reaches for it flips on to stevenson for
the out and the third inning is done it
is 5-1 indians and that's his third walk
they've come in the last two innings and
the indians have a one out base runner
with good speed and miles straw
now he slugs one up the alley left
center field that's going to get down
and go to the wall
look at straw flying around the bags
he's around third he'll score easy
ahmed's going for a third he goes in
safely with an rbi triple oh
speed kills yeah there was no question
straw would score in rosario
he gets it rolling on the bases he is
fun to watch
and there was no question he would try
for three once that ball split the gap
here's jose ramirez he tripled his last
time up
deep right field
down the line it goes cristianos is out
of room it's out of here a two-run homer
for ramirez his 25th of the season it's
a three run fourth for cleveland and
they lead it eight to one luis castillo
who had a 191
era since the first of june and the
indians knock him out with eight runs
the most runs he had allowed in a game
since may 13th in colorado got him
chipped away now just a fly ball you
don't want to give up the out but get a
run back
castellanos
center field caught by straw indian tags
he scores
bradley zimmer will lead it off for the
tribe and the pitch swung on hit high
hit deep to center aquino backtrack wall
gone
a predictious blast to death center
into the trees
near heritage park by bradley zimmer
and the indians lead it nine to two and
that was measured at
471 feet that'll bring up ahmed rosario
in a liner right center field and a
diving attempt by aquino but he won't
make the play look at him go and a mid
head long into second base with a double
it's his fourth hit of the night his
second for extra bases
and now rookie nick sandlin
1-0 with a 220 era runner at second now
tucker barnhart the matter
barnhart turns on that one shoots it
into right
suarez rounds third suarez scores
barnhart slides into second base an rbi
double nine to three the reds are down
to their last out
right field
book it
the indians hang on to the ohio cup they
pummel the reds in the season finale 9-3